[Musica]
tutti noi negoziamo scegliere un
ristorante decidere con la partner cosa
mangiare dove andare in vacanza se
concedere o no due ore in più di
instagram o di videogioco ai ragazzi
chiedere un collega un cambio turno
chiedere al capo un aumento chiedere uno
sconto su un paio di scarpe organizzare
una partita di calcio o il gruppo del
padre
ma anche sviluppare un computer mettendo
assieme competenze diverse progettare
tecnologie complesse come può essere un
treno ad alta velocità un satellite un
farmaco
noi siamo negoziazione ogni passo ogni
respiro della nostra vita passa per la
negoziazione e la maggior parte delle
volte non ce ne rendiamo neanche conto
siamo negoziazione perché viviamo in un
sistema di relazioni
un sistema che è quello umano basato su
la il collegamento tra le persone che ci
piaccia o no
eppure siamo talmente
pur essendo talmente collegati alle
dinamiche della negoziazione tante e
tante volte questo fenomeno ci crea
disagio fastidio a volte conflitto
ci sono infatti alcune tendenze naturali
di fronte alla negoziazione
la prima è quella di rifuggire
discostarsi di scappare al confronto
di chiudersi in una zona di comfort
tanti di voi avranno probabilmente un
parente un amico che ha abituato ad
avere le sue abitudini
di quelli che tu se gli chiedi cosa fa
il sabato la domenica e di proponi
qualcosa di diverso probabilmente vi
risponderà che ha troppo da fare che non
può venire ma sei sicuro che se
piombasse a casa sua la domenica
pomeriggio lo troveresti col telecomando
in mano sul divano e poi ci sono quelli
che io definisco il super in gate quelli
che hanno proprio voglia di negoziare
quelli che nella negoziazione trovano
energia che vogliono dirti la loro a
tutti i costi
quelli che per dirti la loro arrivano a
consigliarti di non bere l'acqua gasata
perché ti fa male non lasciami stare
avevo io so bene cosa mi fa l'acqua
gassata bene
negoziare vuol dire fare la fatica di
spostarsi da una zona nota da uno spazio
per proprio e personale per andare a
conquistare uno spazio diverso uno
spazio che non è né to one suo magari
nuovo magari più largo magari più ricco
ecco la negoziazione è un po questo ed
io
ho la fortuna di fare questo mestiere di
scegliere di negoziare in un contesto
molto particolare
chi fa il mio mestiere infatti questo
percorso lo chiama innovazione la
generazione di valore che viene dal
confronto e quello che porterà più
avanti i confini della conoscenza e
confini della nostra del progresso della
nostra civiltà io lo faccio in un
contesto molto particolare perché da
tanto tempo mi occupo di mettere assieme
due mondi molto diversi due mondi che
viaggiano su dinamiche diverse su
obiettivi diversi su criteri di misura
diverse
lo chiamiamo technology transfer e il
mondo di chi avvicina la ricerca
scientifica ai processi industriali al
mercato di chi tira fuori da quei
laboratori i trovati della scienza e
cerca di trasformarli in prodotti che
possono entrare nelle nostre nelle case
di ognuno di voi il vostro cellulare il
tessuto della sedia su cui siete seduti
oggi i fari di questo teatro
tutte queste tecnologie sono passate
attraverso un percorso che il
trasferimento tecnologico
quando sei di fronte ai migliori
scienziati al mondo e siamo fortunati
l'italia esprime sia sul fronte della
ricerca che sul fronte dell'industria le
migliori eccellenze mondiali bene quando
sei di fronte a dei robotici ad esempio
egli propone di far diventare prodotto
il loro lavoro
una piattaforma che ha insieme
progettazione meccanica
elettronica software
modalità di interazione nel parlato
l'intelligenza artificiale machine
learning ecco quando tutto questo deve
diventare prodotto beh lì cominciano i
problemi del technology transfer ciò che
agli occhi di un imprenditore dovrebbe
infiammare il cuore di ognuno vedere la
propria
attività il proprio lavoro a diventare
prodotto in molti casi incontra
tentennamenti e a volte distacco
siamo di fronte al criterio per cui due
mondi diversi parlano linguaggi diversi
ciò che per un ricercatore e alla fine
del lavoro e cioè l'arrivo ad un trovato
la divulgazione per un imprenditore è
l'inizio di un lavoro che
l'industrializzazione la ricerca del
mercato l'incrocio con le logiche della
produzione della produttività
linguaggi priorità codici culturali
rischiamo di essere di fronte ad un
disallineamento ad un mismatch che
rischia di disperdere in questa
negoziazione tantissima ricchezza ecco
nel fare questo mestiere mi sono a lungo
chiesto dopo aver ascoltato ore di
negoziazione difficili come riuscire a
mettere insieme questi due mondi
qualcuno prima di me sicuramente si sarà
imbattuto in questo stress
ho studiato molto ma non mi si è accesa
la scintilla
finché a un certo punto mi sono
imbattuto in una figura a me molto cara
che sin da ragazzo e mi ha accompagnato
la figura di ettore majorana e del suo
genio incompreso
ettore majorana per chi non lo
conoscesse è un fisico teorico nasce a
catania nel 1906 e cresce nella scuola
di enrico fermi tra quello che fu
definito il gruppo dei ragazzi di via
panisperna un gruppo di fisici che segnò
un secolo di storia nel campo della
fisica
ettore majorana lo zio ettore di cui ero
goloso dei racconti quando in famiglia
se ne parlava e ben ettore è una persona
particolarmente speciale tanto speciale
che lo stesso enrico fermi di lui disse
ma poi ci sono i geni come galileo
newton e ben ettore era uno di quelli
mai ora va aveva quel che nessun altro
al mondo ha
nel breve periodo in cui abbiamo qualche
traccia del suo lavoro
pubblico nove articoli
l'ultimo di questi pubblicato nel 1937
era talmente denso di significato e di
contenuti che fu compreso quasi 30 anni
dopo grazie all'intervento di edoardo
amaldi che lo tradusse lo mandò in
inglese al fisico franklin il quale lo
comprese e lo pubblico sull'american
journal of physics strabiliando i suoi
colleghi
c'era l'equazione infinite variabili
oggi utilizzata per descrivere campi di
particelle ma ancora nei suoi appunti
troviamo tracce dei gruppi matematici
prima ancora che per lo stesso lavoro
bittner vinse il premio nobel troviamo
l'indicazione della scoperta del
neutrone prima che per quel lavoro
charlip vinse il premio nobel
troviamo e ne abbiamo traccia anche
della collaborazione con heisenberg che
aveva vinto il premio nobel per il
principio di indeterminazione che
secondo ettore andava corretto andava
esteso e lo stesso ai sembrarlo invito a
farlo stupendo ettore che era schivo e
che non aveva nessuna voglia di far
vedere il suo lavoro in genere
oggi quel lavoro prende il nome delle
forze di heisenberg majorana
così come quando si confrontò con la
teoria dei neutrini e degli antineutrini
per la quale ed iraq aveva vinto il
nobel beh lui formula una matematica
un'algebra che supera una limitazione
della teoria di dirac artificiosa come
il mare di dirac
ettore era costantemente in anticipo sui
tempi una mente straordinaria ricca di
tantissime tantissime scoperte
eppure era schivo
doveva trovarsi in un suo ambiente aveva
bisogno dei suoi linguaggi dei suoi
codici probabilmente l'apice della sua
carriera felicità scientifica l'ha
raggiunta nel 1933 quando in quegli anni
aveva possibilità di relazionarsi con
geni come enrico fermi che riusciva
interagire con lui come heisenberg
all'ipsia dove andò a lavorare
o come i fisici della scuola di
copenaghen dove bora aveva raccolto i
più grandi fisici del suo tempo un
periodo felice carico di progetti si
leggono nelle sue lettere
e la domanda a questo punto è ma cosa
successe
cosa successe perché lì a qualche anno
un genio così straordinario decide di
sparire senza lasciare traccia di sé
non ho una verità per voi questa sera
eppure probabilmente avrà inciso il
fatto che i tempi intorno a lui erano
cambiati in italia c'era il fascismo
entravano le leggi razziali vi erano i
venti di guerra
ma mio avviso più di ogni altra cosa ha
detto era in quel momento mankoff the
man in the middle
l'uomo di mezzo qualcuno capace di
aiutarlo a negoziare con il mondo
intorno a sé qualcuno che gli
consentisse di relazionarsi di uscire
dal suo spazio di parlare la sua lingua
e di entrare in relazione con il mondo
intorno
ebbene allora probabilmente nello
scegliere il mestiere che faccio oggi la
figura di ettore stata preziosa perché
lì che ho capito che a volte
accanto al genio hai bisogno di avere
the man in the middle
chi aiuti quella persona a relazionarsi
col mondo a svolgere la sua negoziazione
a entrare in relazione per non
disperdere ricchezza
e allora vi dico quando di fronte a una
negoziazione avrete la tentazione di
chiudervi
perché non avete voglia di confrontarvi
o di affermare la vostra verità perché
sapete già la risposta fatevi una
domanda
chiedetevi che cosa stia succedendo se
per caso non sarebbe meglio ascoltare
fatevi venire il dubbio cercate chi vi
fa venire il dubbio perché da loro si
impara e si crea valore
provate ad essere anche voi da man in
the middle
[Applauso]
[Musica]